eu vim falar que a constituição
brasileira é muito branda se comparada à
americana por exemplo no que diz
respeito à punição de jovens de crianças
e adolescentes infratores
lá há 14 anos a idade suficiente para
que qualquer adolescente vai à cadeia
aliás em alguns estados do país 12 anos
uma adolescente com 12 anos que pratica
algum crime ele vai ele pode pegar a
mesma pena que um adulto e isso vai
desde a prisão perpétua a pena de morte
aqui no brasil o adolescente ele pode
cometer crimes graves e ele fica apenas
por assim dizer apreendido sob custódia
é o termo correto
e aí você deve estar se perguntando o
que eu estou fazendo aqui falando sobre
direito penal nem eu não sou
especialista na área sou jornalista por
formação como foi apresentada a questão
é que uma coisa existe em comum entre
esses dois países o nosso país estados
unidos que eu usei como exemplo e que
saem todo mundo acredita que vocês
conhecem muito bem dessa lei e não
precisa ser especialista em nada para
conhecê-la
a chamada lei da vida essa é implacável
uma escolha errada você vai pagar caro
muito caro por isso
como é que eu fiz em 1997 quando eu tive
o meu primeiro emprego conseguiu o
primeiro emprego era a mesma época e
época também que ainda sonhava em ter
uma festa de 15 anos e que escolha foi
essa
eu escolhi o meu primeiro namorado uau
todas as minhas amigas já tinha namorado
e eu não tinha me sentia super atrasada
por isso fora que a minha irmã mais
velha que eu modelava eu gostava da cor
que ela gostava tudo o que ela gostava
desde pequenininha era assim eu gostava
também ela falou que ele era bonito
então opa
a minha escolha realmente estou certa e
além do mais os meus pais não se
opuseram a isso mesmo ele sendo 20 anos
mais velho do que eu entendo outros
quatro filhos de três outras relacionar
eu diria que não é um currículo muito
bacana porque é um garoto de 14 anos
começasse um relacionamento e essa
escolha que eu fiz e até o entender isso
que a questão estava na minha escolha o
problema não foi deus para quem crê que
existe um os meus pais a minha irmã era
culpa de ninguém só era minha me levou
um carro ser emocional e uma pena
auto-imposta de 19 anos e me libertar
desse cárcere foi a tarefa mais
desafiadora da minha vida
e como é que eu fiz isso eu fiz isso
sozinha sem a ajuda de nada nem de
ninguém sem a ajuda de psicólogos
coxinhas família amigos e eu não falo
isso aqui por arrogância nem pra dizer
que eu sou melhor do que ninguém porque
se eu conseguir todo mundo consegue
certo
eu falo isso para que fique claro de que
é a nossa escolha e esse é o primeiro
conceito eu queria que ficasse claro pra
vocês auto-responsabilidade muitas vezes
nos colocamos em cáceres por causa das
nossas escolhas e não por causa do outro
cada um só dá o que tem
eu recebi o que o outro tinha para me
dar e esse caráter emocional no meu caso
foi de um relato relacionamento
agressivo
é só abrir um parêntese aqui pode ser em
qualquer outra área está muitas vezes
estamos fazendo um curso é que não é o
curso que gostaríamos de fazer mas
fazemos para agradar pai mãe irmão
família etc
muitas vezes um avô que já é falecido
ou estamos na amizade tóxica porque não
tenho porque ficamos lá nela então de
mita amizades tóxicas limita tudo que te
leva um caráter emocional e como é que
eu saí do meu se eu disse que eu saí
sozinha sem ter por exemplo conhecimento
sobre inteligência emocional que é hoje
é um tema que eu domino
eu precisei sair do palco que encenava a
minha vida
mas antes de sair eu precisei ter
consciência do que estava acontecendo
comigo porque a gente só muda mediante
quatro situações medo do
o constrangimento ou consciência
esse último quarto é o único que é
interno é de dentro para fora
agora como é que eu precisei ter
consciência se eu já passava pelos
outros três fatores dor porque lá no
castelão ambiente de dor
lá a gente chora a gente não rio adentro
constrangimento também passava
constrangimento em todos os lugares que
eu morei em todos os lugares que eu
estudei eu era muito humilhada medo
também o medo era algo que me assombrava
como assim eu iria libertar disso como é
que as pessoas vão me olhar como é que a
sociedade me valorizar
eu já tinha dois filhos e como é que
ficaria para minha família como seria
minha vida depois disso como iriam me
olhar no meu ambiente de trabalho era
algo bem desafiador mas nenhum desses
foram suficientes
até eu ter a tomada de consciência
consciência de que tudo estava errado
consciência de que não era aquela vida
que eu queria viver eu precisava ser a
protagonista da minha vida então eu saí
do palco em que eu estava ensinando a
minha vida e sentei na platéia
eu comecei a observar o que estava
acontecendo
eu vi que aquela vida que eu estava
encenando não era vida que eu queria
viver que eu fui criada para viver
eu não era protagonista que sentido
faria eu era apenas um fantoche
conduzida por alguém eu não era sequer a
coadjuvante porque a coadjuvante ela
ainda tem um papel para encenar e quando
você não tem identidade
você não sabe nem o que você está
fazendo nesse palco da vida e quando eu
sentei na platéia comecei a observar
eu vi que estava tudo errado e olha só
duas coisas incríveis a descobrir
primeiro que a gente só tem essa vida o
al e segundo que ela é um sopro ou seja
se eu queria mudar aquele cenário porque
a vida é ao vivo
ela não é uma gravação eu sou jornalista
e apresentadora de tv em programas
gravados ao vivo gravado após huíla para
vai repetir-se não ficou bom na vida não
é assim ou é ou não é
e à vida em agora sabe aquela coisa que
a gente ouve por aí pude ser feliz é
hoje não tá errado é agora a hora de ser
feliz é agora então precisava agir
eu já estava 19 anos nesse ambiente de
dor nesse palco de dor de angústia
eu precisava reagir e o que eu fiz eu
pensei bons somos constituídos por 11
pilares eu vou compactuar tudo em três
corpo alma e espírito e vou trabalhar
seus três áreas porque a gente só
depende da gente
se eu fosse esperar que deus para quem
crê que existe um fizesse algo por mim o
presidente o país à crise mudar os meus
pais a família os meus amigos alguém
tivesse pena de mim nada ia acontecer
a vítima sabe existem pessoas e eu era
uma dessas que preferem se vitimizar
fica ali no ambiente de dor porque ali
alguém vai passar a mão na sua cabeça e
sair dele passa a ser protagonista da
sua história requer coragem que muitas
vezes a gente não encontra ela quando
está lá porque nunca seria assim eu
costumo dizer que existe uma cadeirinha
chamada de zona de desconforto porque
detesto essa expressão zona de conforto
conforto é algo bom concorda é uma zona
de desconforto a gente ficar sentadinho
por causa de dois motivos o primeiro é
um medo que é uma das crianças mas
limitadores que existem
o medo e o meu medo era o medo da
rejeição caramba
ninguém vai mais à minha mãe ninguém
mais a minha marca descobrirem as minhas
dores quando descobrirem por tudo que eu
passo por toda agressão física moral e
psicológica à qual está submetida o ao
logo vocês de uma mulher tão esclarecida
pois é eu e por que eu passava por isso
porque sem ter conhecimento na época eu
aplicava todo o comportamento da minha
mãe que também teve uma jornada bem
traumática no casamento
então eu apanhava mas estava tudo bem
foi escolha que eu fiz
carrega sua cruz pro resto da vida eu
quase perco meu filho no emblemático
revellion do ano 2000 quando eu peguei o
pai dele na cama com outra e eu ainda
ganhei por isso não era pro time naquele
momento
eu passava por toda agressão física
psicológica e emocional moral
todas elas mas eu tava linha final foi
escolha que eu fiz eu casei para viver o
resto da vida
então você imagine que eu vivi o tal do
luto possa relacionamento
ainda morando porque eu não aceitava
minha própria decisão
tamanho era minha tamanha era a minha
crença de que eu precisava passar por
isso de que foi a minha escolha e ponto
final
e quando eu comecei a equilibrar esses
três pilares corpo alma e espírito
comecei pelo corpo
porque quando você está no cárcere não
existe a autoestima
não é que ela tá baixo alta ela não
existe
você olha para a sua vida e diz que
sentido faz ela eu não sou boa pra nada
eu não conquisto nada eu não sou bonita
não sou feliz eu não sou nada eu sou
nada e daí eu tentei tirar minha vida
por duas vezes à final que sentido fazia
viver
mesmo já tendo filho mas pra mim não
fazia mais sentido tamanha era a
depressão porque o nosso corpo físico é
só um reflexo do que está por dentro e
eu demorei muito a entender isso é tanto
que quando me libertei do castelo já
indo lá pro final
as pessoas me diziam nossa como você tá
diferente o que você fez e está mais
bonita
não fiz nada nem botox eu atualizei não
fiz nada mas é porque o nosso corpo
físico reflete que está por dentro o
nosso rosto é o painel de led do nosso
interior
e aí eu descobrir nessa jornada que o
posicionamento mental é mais importante
do que talento é mais importante do que
a condição física é mais importante do
que qualquer outra coisa ou seja a alma
o segredo estava aqui eu descobri que
aqui é a cabine de controle e que se eu
tivesse domínio sobre ela eu iria
conquistar o mundo
imagine um barco era como um barco e eu
tinha o timão na mão o timão do barco
era meu então o vento da circunstância
poderia existir poderia ser forte e
tenebroso poderia ser como fosse mas o
timão do barco era meu então quando o
vento viesse
vir a impedir que o barco se chocar se
contra as pedras
esse foi o primeiro e mais importante
passo foi descobrir que aqui quem manda
sou eu eu sou a dona da minha vida eu
fui feita para viver os meus sonhos
imagine um avião haviam feito pra voar
concorda
um avião no chão ele se deteriore seja
muito mais rápido ele tem de ferro já
que ele não foi criado para isso e eu
fui criada para viver os meus sonhos
então não fazia sentido estar num palco
encenando uma vida sem sonhos tentando
tirá la a todo custo o que era que seria
e daí eu entendi esse processo que eu
precisava ser a minha prioridade e que
precisava parar de tratar os outros como
prioridade pessoas que só me tratavam
como opção e eu descobrir que a pessoa
que eu mais amo as pessoas não eram os
meus dois filhos não era os meus pais
nas mãos não era ninguém eu precisava
ser a pessoa que eu mais amava na vida
eu precisava se a pessoa mais importante
especial para mim porque só uma pessoa
inteira é capaz de amar o outro na
totalidade
então se os meus filhos eram tão
importante pra mim eu precisava ser
inteira plena realizada e feliz
para amá los como eles mereciam e essa
saída do palco foi crucial para esse
entendimento
quando eu fiz tudo isso eu entendi que
também espiritual não conseguiria porque
eu falei sobre liberdade
eu falei sobre crime e falei sobre a lei
da vida e o criador né pra quem concorda
ou não que existe ele poderia dar para a
criatura um caminho para seguir mas ele
deixou livre livre para viver os sonhos
e é isso que somos então eu resgatei
todos os meus sonhos do túmulo todos
quando resolvi mercado esse cara ele foi
fácil não foi
foi muito desafiador mas eu quero que
fique essa lição essa compartilhando a
oab a minha expertise a minha
experiência é quando você se liberta de
sikasso imagine alguém que está preso
durante 19 anos morando na cadeia e olha
que a cadeia física tem grades ela
de adn um agente penitenciário muro
cerca elétrica sistema de segurança
eletrônico tem guarita de segurança e é
muito mais fácil sair dele do que do
câncer emocional que não tem nada disso
porque lá existe um medo que nos limita
o medo sobretudo da rejeição que vão
achar de mim
só que quem tem medo do ridículo jamais
se aproxima do extraordinário e é isso
que eu tenho vivido o extraordinário
porque eu ousei me levantar da cadeira e
dizer opa eu sou a minha prioridade
e quando eu passei desse câncer e estou
livre
é como se estivesse submersa no oceano e
vinha à tona e respirei eu ganhei um
fôlego novo de viver e outrora quando eu
me sentia uma fracassada porque eu
voltei pra casa dos meus pais com 34
anos e dois filhos para uma pessoa que
começou a trabalhar você lembra aos 14
como o office girl porque queria sua
liberdade financeira foi um fracasso me
sentia que eu regredi toda a minha vida
e agora tinha mais duas vidas que
dependiam de mim e aí quero que
acontecer
a depressão queria vir novamente mas
leôpa aquela não se instalar mais
enxugue as lágrimas depois de três dias
e disse eu não posso me dar ao luxo de
ficar com mimi
mimi não é pra mim afinal de contas eu
tenho mais duas outras vidas que
dependem de mim e se eu não ficava com
mimi quando era eu sozinha agora então
eu não posso ficar quem conduz esse
barco que tem mais dois de tripulação
sou eu então enxugar lágrimas lágrimas
depois de três dias e resolvi ficar em
campo eu resgatei o meu sobrenome de
batismo em ninguém me conhecia a minha
cidade era mais de dez anos de carreira
tendo outro nome não tem problema
zerei também a minha vida profissional
porque já tinha gerado todas as outras
áreas
eu saí de casa eu decidi mudar eu deixei
para trás 19 anos de construção material
de tudo não tem problema eu saí com o
principal propriedade que era minha paz
e nesse tempo resgatar o meu sobrenome
de batismo escrever um livro que corpos
musculosos algumas obesas e esse título
se dá exatamente por isso é um livro
autobiográfico
há quem entenda que não adianta tudo bem
por fora tudo dentro dos padrões
agradando a todo mundo se por dentro
existe uma alma o besa cheia da cultura
da opressão e da dor
fomos criados para dar certo fomos
criados para sermos felizes ea
felicidade de dentro pra fora
isso vai determinar tudo posicionamento
no meio ambiente muda tudo
como é que você tem se posicionado eu
prefiro me posicionar como a vencedora
como a mulher que resgata que fez da don
combustível para alavancar toda sua vida
porque a dor a larga às articulações do
espírito pra quem quer que alargue para
quem quer crescer porque a opção sempre
será nossa a escolha sempre será nossa
você pode pegar sua dor e deixar lá
cavar um poço cavar um buraco em um
cavalo mais um pouquinho e cinto e ralar
ou você pode mudar a sua história
sou eu pude mudar a minha história só
você pode mudar sua história
então mudei o meu sobrenome resgatemos
sobrenome de batismo eu sou gilmar
gonçalves com muito orgulho e escrevi um
livro para ajudar pessoas a se
libertarem também a viver os seus sonhos
eu informei hoje o coaching integral
sistêmico com especialidade em
relacionamento para ajudar pessoas a não
viver um relacionamento precisa como eu
vivi eu criei um método chamado rábica
em relação ao relacionamento de alto
valor para que você atraia aquilo que
você é para que as pessoas resgatar sua
autoestima e veja o valor que tenho
quando especial são porque só quando
você entende quem verdadeiramente você é
você é capaz de atrair alguém igual a
você
a culpa não estava no outro o corpo
estava em mim eu ou atrair a gente atrai
aquilo que a gente é quem é você quem
era eu quem sou eu hoje eu me tornei
coach como eu falei mentor e palestrante
eu tenho palestrado há um ano para mais
de 10 mil pessoas
eu acabei de chegar a dois dias de
londres onde eu fui atender a uma
cliente da qual seu mentor a coach e
gosto site dela
feito o livro dela e agora quem diria
estou aqui no tapete vermelho do pedex
castro
isso porque eu sou melhor do que ninguém
não jeito nenhum
apenas porque eu resolvi sair do cárcere
que me oprime a apenas porque resolvi
ser diferente apenas porque eu não me
conformei está ali eu preferisse uma
inconformada e eu sou até hoje porque eu
digo você é só o começo eu ainda nem
comecei ou seja aquela mulher que
outrora com 34 anos e achava velha pra
qualquer coisa e achava que realmente a
vida tinha acabado ali
ela precisava apenas viver porque ela
tinha dois filhos para criar
ela está aqui com fôlego de vida ela nem
lembra que tem 36 anos
afinal nem parece né ela tá aqui louca
pra viver e realmente está só começando
e está porque eu tomei posse do meu alto
valor porque entendi que eu sou a minha
prioridade e desde então nunca mais eu
aceitei menos do que eu mereço muita
gratidão todos